Lee! Lee!
Oh, [bleep]!
Oh, Lee, I'm sorry,
buddy.
I can't believe it.
Thank you so much
for coming.
I haven't seen you
in years.
Oh...
Yeah.
Oh!
Yeah, hey.
Stuart!
- Yes!
- Man.
Oh, I haven't seen you since--
- Eighth grade.
- Miss Lacy's class?
- Yeah...I know, I know.
Miss Lacy's Class!
Ha ha!
Oh, you brought me
flowers?
Mm-hmm.
That's awesome.
I bought these at a store
for you.
You didn't have
to bring me flowers, man.
Here you go.
Crazy the way
I went out like that, huh?
- Yeah.
- What was that?
- What?
I was like, when I heard,
I was like, "What the [bleep]?"
Oh, well of course, I mean--
[bleep] Boulder?
Who'd have thought!
Boulder. Right.
I mean it's like,
who gets killed
by a boulder these days?
Well, I mean--I mean,
not me.
I mean, you remember, I was
in Boulder, Colorado.
I was hiking, and then
I fell off that mountain.
Remember?
You remember, right?
Boulder, Colorado.
- Yeah!
- I was hiking, and then I--
- No, I-I know!
- I was dehydrated,
then they
couldn't find me.
No, I was saying,
like, if you think about it,
Boulder killed you.
Well, not really Boulder.
I wouldn't say the city,
per se.
It was the--it was the cougar
that got me.
And then that's what everyone
was talking about.
I mean, God, I was out there
for like, three weeks.
- Yeah.
- Jeez.
But that's neither here
nor there.
So, hey, did you get
that LinkedIn invitation
I sent you before I died?
I--you know,
um, I mean, I don't--
when I see LinkedIn,
I just delete it
without even checking,
- because I've just got...
- No, no, I got you.
- so much...on my plate.
- Totally, yeah, yeah.
- I get it, I get it.
- So...
Hey, so w-what
did you want to say to me?
- Um, what do you mean?
- You know, that's why
people come
to graveyards, right?
Is so you can say
the stuff
- that you wish you had said...
- Right, right--
when someone was alive,
right?
Oh, my God.
There's so much stuff.
Okay, where do I start?
- Um...
- Take your time, man.
You can lay a couple on me today
and then come back.
Yeah, I mean--yeah,
I can get it done here.
'Cause that's the whole reason
I came down here, you know.
- Sure. Yeah, yeah.
Plus my grandfather's
like two rows down there.
- Oh.
- I was gonna come to you,
say some things to you,
go to him,
and sort of finish up...
- Oh...
- there.
But you were coming
to see me too?
Totally, totally, totally.
Well, fire away, man.
You're the only good friend
I have who's come to visit.
Yeah.
Really? Yeah.
Uh-huh.
I just wanted to, uh,
say that, oh,
if you see my grandfather,
maybe you could
just tell him that--
Okay, so you didn't
come here to visit me.
You came here
to see your grandfather.
I get it.
Well, what do you mean?
What are you talking about?
Oh--pffft!
[bleep], please.
I'm here to see you.
- Why--
- Right.
Okay. It's cool.
You know what,
I'm just gonna, you know,
go back to the afterlife.
I'm sorry.
I'm behind hostile.
It's just a little
embarrassed right now,
- a little taken off guard.
- I'm just gonna...
No, go ahead, take them.
Get them.
- Yeah.
- Go ahead, get them, Get them.
[mumbling]
Oh, uh,
just a heads up, though, Lee.
Um, I'm probably gonna haunt you
for the rest of your life,
and if you have a daughter,
I'm gonna
possess the creepiest doll
- in her bedroom.
- No.
- Just so you know.
- No, no, no, no, no,
wait, wait, wait.
Stevie, Stevie, Stevie.
Stuart!